so lud ich ärger mich fürchterlich
darüber wie die regierenden mit unserem
geld umgehen und ich meine damit nicht
die transferleistungen oder die die
hilfsleistungen für flutopfer je mehr
geld uns die regierung zurück überweist
desto besser mir geht es darum wie die
regierung damit umgehen mit dem
gemeinsam geld damit umgeht denn ist um
ihre eigenen prachtbauten geht das
nämlich kaum jemand mitbekommt im
schatten dieser welt ereignisse befindet
in berlin unglaubliche bauvorhaben stand
das bundeskanzleramt zb kriegt einen
neuen flügel für millionen euro wird der
neue flügel dran geklärt wenn das
bundeskanzleramt weil die offenbar mehr
raumbedarf haben dazu kommt eine
helikopter landeplatz der allein der
helikopter landeplatz kostet
16 millionen euro alleine helikopter
landeplätze widme mich auch so beton
stelzen stehen in 23 meter höhe weil
und die statik ist so schwierig bei
seinem hohen helikopterlandeplatz ist
diese dass diese betonteile sich 20
metern in den boden müssen das
unglaublich was ihr geld für seine
extravaganz im grunde ausgegeben mit
gleichzeitig wird das schloss bellevue
noch mal grundsaniert wo wenn ich mal
etwas
stutzig wurde das gehört habe wenn die
boden dreimal wurde der welt grüner ist
also der sitz unseres bundespräsidenten
schon grundsaniert also sieht es das
dritte mal dran nebenan steht das
bundespräsidialamt ein neubau erst 1998
gebaut auch der muss vollkommen
grundsaniert werden und es werden die
teuersten architekten beauftragt um den
gesamten eingangsbereich 9 zu design hat
man vor 20 jahren auch schon so machen
also früher hat man gebäude so gebaut
dass sie über jahrhunderte blieben heute
wird alle paar jahre umgebaut oder dran
gebaut und die treuesten architekten
werden dafür engagiert und wir sind
diejenigen die zahlen zahlen zahlen und
ich muss sagen ich sehe das nicht ein
ja kann ich nur zustimmen größenwahn
fällt mir dazu nur ein sehr würde denn
hier wir machen eine schnelle abstimmung
wir haben noch 300 seine zeit schnelle
abstimmung wer würde denn sagen dass
alexander fall schlägt und sagen würde
ja die sollen sich ruhig ihre bauten
bauen wenn die bauten denn mal ich würde
das beispiel sagen aber
ich wollte nur ganz gut sagen ich finde
es ehrlich gesagt
vollkommen in ordnung ich habe heute mal
verglichen wir sind nicht mal als unter
den top 10 der teuersten
regierungsgebäuden der welt das hat das
feuer noch annehmen müssen sie alle paar
jahre neu gemacht ein stichwort
der bund als bauherr nicht nur
wahnsinnig verschwendung sondern ist
auch total schließlich das jahr der
bundestag der nächste kunst hat könnte
der größte aller zeiten werden aber wir
haben keinen platz für all diese
abgeordneten war zum beispiel das
marie-elisabeth-lüders-haus ein totales
desaster ist da gab es risse in der
bodenwanne da musst du das jetzt
community mal geborsten jedoch ist es
immer gerkhan und ich weil sie wurde
erst ziehen sich aber jahre nach dem
brauch jetzt ist es auch 2023 ist jetzt
der neue eröffnungstermin ja und bis
dahin dürfen da immer noch keine
abgeordnete einzigen diese sitzen jetzt
ein baucontainer es ist leider einfach
nur desaströs der bund als bauherr da
kann man sich schon mal auf br
verhältnisse einstellen aber da ist doch
das problem dass dieses parlament immer
weiter wächst und wir so viele
abgeordnete haben und nicht dass es
nicht gut platz gibt doch ich würde das
eher aber ich würde ja erde zu kreieren
weniger dass es weniger abgeordnete gibt
und wir nicht mehr weit china
übertreffen sondern ich habe jetzt mehr
gebäude zu bauen zweifelslos aber die
gebäude die man hat und die schon 2016
hätten eingeweiht werden sollen wäre
doch schön wenn wir irgendwann mal
fertig würden also ich glaube wir dürfen
nicht ablenken ich finde ich finde die
die natürlich bundestag wächst zu viel
aber das ist ein ganz anderes thema ich
finde es problematisch wie die ewige der
staat mit unserem geld umgeht und ich
finde das bewusstsein ist gar nicht
wirklich da dass es unser geld ist ich
will mehr ich finde wenn ich werde ich
mir noch mal auf das tri l zurückkommen
die reden alle über steuererhöhungen die
reden alle über steuererhöhungen das ist
das ist unser geld und dann gleichzeitig
bauen die in berlin hier soll es also so
architektonische fantasie
die kopten landeplätze so james bond
mäßig mit
uns mit
worden also die bild berichtet
jackson geschrieben haben ich finde
das ist ein schönes schlusswort
alexander für die heutige sendung werden
wir uns bestimmt alle einig mehr respekt
für den steuerzahler und dass der
steuerzahler wäre vielleicht sollte man
sich mal bei ihnen bedanken flächen
dankesschreiben auf jeden fall mehr
respekt
[Musik]